then America was saved
embraced by The Loving Arms of our new
President Joe Biden Biden has brought
back kindness and decorum
look fat look here's a deal no I wish
you were in high school I could take him
behind the gym
[Music]
Biden is a voice of clarity America is a
nation that can be defined in a single
word
I was in foot
a voice of reason he is the smartest man
I know he gonna put you all back in
Chains and he's good with numbers let me
start off with two words
made in America 700 billion and a
trillion 300 million billion dollars
under his leadership the Biden
Administration has brought us safety it
has brought us economic Prosperity it
has empowered the Next Generation and
now you have the chance to make sure it
continues for another two years this
election day vote for whoever the Biden
Administration is asking you to vote for
they know what's best together we will
ensure things will continue to go the
way they've been going forever
ever I'm sure Biden and I approve this
this uh wait wait who you know the thing
see guys the internet is not always
horrible occasionally it is a fun funny
irreverent place a place where memes can
spread ideas faster than ideas traveled
in past days it is November 3rd 2022 I'm
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report we
are on live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and Blaze TV if you have not subscribed
to our channels go ahead and do it it's
like how many times I have to tell you
this if you do it I'll just stop saying
it enough already with this you know
what I'm saying uh we are mostly today
focusing on a Reuben report uh locals
Community Q a uh got a bunch of great
questions all over the the map
politically personally all over uh so
we'll get to that in just a moment uh I
wanted to start though today with this
appearance yesterday you know I'm trying
to limit the amount of stuff we do with
the view it's a constant internal
conflict here like you know on one hand
it's like the ladies of the view are
insane the show is awful we shouldn't
pay much attention to them and then on
the other hand because there is an
influential set of people that do watch
the program it's like we should be
exposing this stuff this is also of
course how I feel about MSNBC and joy
read and a lot of the CNN stuff and
everything else what I would hope is
that when we get to the other side of
next week so let's say Tuesday goes
pretty well and you know suddenly the
Senate is looking pretty red and New
York maybe went red in Michigan and
Arizona and things are really really
turning my hope is that going forward we
can focus more on those constant
positive stories related to freedom and
economic prosperity and human
flourishing and have to focus a little
less on the lunacy but as long as the
lunacy is encroaching which it still is
of course and as I said yesterday it's
never going to go away even if we defeat
it
at The Ballot Box for the most part it's
not going to fully go away but I think
as we start winning more and it feels
like we're on the precipice of that we
can kind of shift and and focus on the
New Horizon instead of just always
dealing with the lunatics but in any
event uh Anne Hathaway actress Anne
Hathaway uh from Devil Wears Prada she
was an Interstellar give me one more
Anne Hathaway movie
princess wow you got very excited on
that one car you just lit up princess
diaries okay do you have one you have
one
no you have to say that properly Les
Miserables
Les Mis Les Mis Les Miserables
no guacamole for you uh anyway Anne
Hathaway the actress she was on The View
yesterday and of course what happens
when an actress goes on The View we're
gonna do abortion and racism and
chopping kids genitals off and
everything else so we're gonna hit a
little bit of that and then we'll get to
the questions real quick guys let me
talk to you about bullion Max you know
as inflation surpasses highs not seen in
40 years don't tell Joe Biden the value
of the dollar is decreasing with every
passing day you're paying more at the
pump the grocery store for cars and
housing face it paper money is worth
less guys The Limited the timing
couldn't be any better for my new
sponsor bullion Max bullion Max is a
direct to Consumer precious metals
retailer who can help you diversify into
gold and silver it's a hedge against
inflation it's also security for your
family in times of Crisis and here's why
I love bullying max they're owned by
veterans in the precious metals space
offer some of the lowest prices on the
internet and they make it so easy to buy
directly from their website I want to
help get you started so I worked out a
special offer her with them just for you
get bullion Max's silver starter kit at
employee pricing just go to
booleanmax.com Dave the kit includes
five of the most desirable silver
products products to invest in including
a silver American eagle and a silver
Australian kangaroo this offer is
limited to just one per household so get
yours now go to bullionmax.com Dave
booleanmax.com Dave and now back to me
all right actress Anne Hathaway was on
The View sitting with the harpies
yesterday and you'd think perhaps they
could talk about movies or television or
the craft of acting it's a very serious
thing these are very serious people but
no mostly abortion we're in the fight
every minute and you mentioned the
Devil's Prada turning sweet 16. some 16
year old's life has been irrevocably
changed yeah because of the current
overturning of Roe v Wade I just say one
other thing and just without going into
too many details my own personal
experience with abortion and I don't
think we talk about this enough abortion
can be another word for mercy we don't
know we don't know it's not a world in
which we know that no two pregnancies
are alike and it follows that no two
lives are like that follows that no two
conceptions are alike so how can we have
a law how can we have a point of view on
this that says we must treat everything
the same and where I come at it from is
when you allow for choice you allow for
flexibility which is what we need in
order to be human so that anyway I just
wanted to include that
especially for that it's not it's not
set in stone just because you get
pregnant doesn't mean you get to keep
that baby yeah it's a health decision
and it can be it really can be yeah
God it's so incredible almost everything
she said right there was completely
backwards related to what just happened
with Roe v Wade so we'll do a quick 101
on this and this is one of those moments
where I know I have a bright audience so
it's like why do I have to explain it
but you know we could be getting some
new people who don't know the score uh
Roe v Wade did not the reversal of Roe v
Wade did not make abortion legal uh did
not make abortion illegal all it did was
kick it back to the states which is
exactly how it was before the original
decision I think in 19 what was it 1972
if I'm not mistaken uh that's all it did
so the states then can make choices for
themselves so it's so interesting she
wants flexibility and she wants choice
that is actually the outcome of Roe v
Wade being flipped now each state is
making choices and offering flexibility
to their constituents so here in Florida
right very red right wing DeSantis Stan
Florida we have a 15-week ban on
abortion and there's still some
exceptions after that 15 weeks that's
three and a half months any of you who
have been pregnant or know someone who's
been pregnant or were birthed from
someone who was once pregnant understand
the three and a half weeks the three and
a half months is a pretty reasonable
compromise I would argue that that is
far more of a compromise than say
eight-month abortions that seems rather
excessive if you ask me but the point is
that each state California can have
their eight and nine month and
post-birth abortions and if Kentucky
wants something more strict they can do
that you also have the ability to go to
different states and do different things
you can have non-profits that will allow
people and bus people from one state to
another to either have an abortion or to
not have an abortion this is what
Freedom's all about so everything that
she explained other than she's for
abortion everything she explained was
was completely come completely
nonsensical which is consistent no two
lives are like well of course no two
lives are like so let's give as much
Choice as possible let's not have the
federal government say what everyone has
to do let's leave it to the state there
was a bunch of guys who used to wear
these white wigs and they'd wear these
funny jackets and tall socks and they
were into this sort of uh Choice thing
it's very very bizarre uh anyway uh
let's now shift because it wasn't just
the view yesterday spouting General
nonsense uh NBC there's this thing
called NBC now it's a little unclear to
me what it is I guess it's like they're
like they're trying to be like young hip
NBC or it's their
lgbtq plus NBC something like that they
did a groundbreaking uh little piece
here on how trans people are struggling
to vote your voters are concerned they
might be blocked from casting their
ballots yeah that's because a growing
number of states are enforcing stricter
voter identification laws that
disproportionately in impact the
Community NBC out reporter Joe yourka
joins us now with more on this show good
morning to you so first of all how can
voter ID laws create obstacles for
transgender people and where do we see
some of the strictest voter ID laws
sure yes so voter ID law is
disproportionately impact trans people
because trans people are more likely to
have IDs without the name that they go
by and the gender marker that reflects
how they present and Recent research
shows that just over 200 000 eligible
trans voters in 31 states that both
conduct their elections mostly in person
and require or request ID at the polls
don't have IDs that reflect their gender
identities and the names they go by and
you know the states that have the
strictest voter ID laws are mostly
concentrated in the South and Midwest so
you're you know Tennessee Wisconsin
Kansas so voters there are
oh God they have everybody it's like
there's all the problems over here and
they have everybody looking over here
constantly having an ID that reflects
who you actually are is a key part of
securing a democracy every Western
democracy has this we are basically the
only country at this point in the
Civilized world who for some reason a
certain set of our states have decided
you do not need an ID to vote when I
voted last year in the California recall
election I've told you this many times I
tried to show the guy my ID and he kind
of freaked out all they wanted to know
was your name and your address it's very
bizarre because I knew at the time my
neighbor's name and address and I
suppose I could have gone in the very
next day and said I am him or I am her
and they would have had to let me vote
um are these people implying that these
trans people that they're very worried
about can't get on planes because you
need to play you need an ID to get on a
plane which is of course the same thing
that they're constantly saying about
black people black people can't get ID
is I can't find one black person who
hasn't had gotten an ID as I said
yesterday it's odd that CNN and MSNBC
have not run these videos of all of
these black people being turned away
often I've seen black people on planes
have you guys seen black people on
planes ever yeah we've all seen black
people on planes they seem to be
figuring it out they these it's the soft
bigotry of low expectations these people
are just absolutely ridiculous and if
if you are an adult
who transitions so you're a biological
male let's say you're a 32 year old dude
and now you wish to live as a woman and
you transition whatever that means and
you'd go through whatever procedures and
you legally change your name and
everything else you get a new ID you get
a new ID so these people are just
creating problems it's like the whole
house is burning down and they're
worried about the Dust Bunny in the
corner it is just so silly so so silly
guys there's an election coming and the
blaze wants to help you figure out
what's going on as you know it's right
around the corner this coming Tuesday
and the stakes have never been higher
for the midterms several races across
the country have gotten very interesting
in the past couple weeks will the
Republicans win a senate seat in
Washington state of all places I think
it's possible is Kathy hokel really in
trouble in New York yes will voters
punish Gretchen Whitmer for her covid
lockdown insanity and finally give her
the boot I hope so there's a lot to
cover this election cycle and we've got
you covered Stu Berger who kind of
serves as Blaze me
I can't get this word right see
theologist
cvologist doesn't sound right to me oh
God sephologist
it's a fancy word that means someone who
studies elections wait cephologist
sephologist that doesn't seem right
we're opening up the comment section to
Doom today uh well anyway Steve put
together a comprehensive list to let you
know exactly what you need to look out
for on Election night head on over to
theblaze.com election guide to receive a
free copy of Blaze media's Ultimate
Guide to the midterms delivered straight
to your inbox that's Blaze the blaze.com
election guide and we will send you
everything you need to know to be ready
for the big election night and now back
to me I want to try to read that word
one more time I've got it right in front
of me here so if I have it right now let
me where is the word do I have it here
sepologist does that sound right
cephologist
that doesn't sound like a real word to
me anyway let's move on we got a ruby
report locals Community Q a for you uh
if you want if you're in the chat right
now you can still submit questions maybe
we'll do some on the Fly that's
reubenport.locals.com Chris says my
husband who also happens to be gay I see
what you did there and I have been
married for a year and a half and
together for eight we've uh both been
fairly sure we didn't want children but
I'm beginning to have thoughts about
wanting to adopt what changed your mind
about fatherhood and what advice would
you give a fellow gay couple well look
you know I've told you guys many times
and you can watch my interview uh from
what about three months ago with Jordan
Peterson we have some clips on this
channel and and the full things on
Jordan's channel uh about how he really
when we were on tour helped me move on
children David had wanted children for a
while David's a little younger than me I
grew up in a time in the 90s you know or
80s and 90s where there was no such
thing as gay marriage I never really
thought of my future that way I was
putting everything I had into stand up
and then what became this career so I
was just distracting myself all the time
and it was just I was just living my
life kind of day to day to day and I
suppose in some ways that led to success
right because I put so much into it but
I never thought about that sort of
long-term stuff David again because he
is a little bit younger he grew up in a
time where he knew he was going to get
married one day it didn't seem crazy to
have a family and all that so he wanted
kids and we were married and then I'm
listening to Jordan talking about you
know how how most human beings not
everybody but to live a fully actualized
complete life that having kids and maybe
eventually if you're lucky enough
becoming a grandparent it's so
fundamentally part of the human story
that most people need that to live that
complete life and I was hearing that and
I'm hearing it from David and and then I
just kind of moved on it and I have to
say I'm at the ripe old age of 46 years
old I'm not the youngest parent in the
stable but uh but actually my knee's
been feeling pretty good lately and and
I'm enjoying it uh I've only posted
pictures of the kids in the locals
Community I'm not going to be putting it
all over YouTube and Instagram and
everything else but I thought we'd just
show you this quick 30 second video this
is what we did on on uh Halloween just a
couple days ago and I think you'll see
why parenthood's pretty it's pretty good
all right first Halloween we just
started trick-or-treating here's Justin
the skeleton very excited a little on
the chunky side for a skeleton but still
pretty good there's Luke a little more
skeletony and
there's
Daddy
and Dad
yeah oh and Clyde and Clyde dressed up
as Clyde there you go happy Halloween
so yeah we were out there with all the
other families and I gotta tell you even
here in Florida nobody was weird that
there were two dads and anything and
think about it if we didn't have kids
and we were just two dudes out there
pushing strollers with no kids in them
that would have been weird
that was funny guys thank you Connor
getting nothing out of these two that
was funny you know what I mean just two
dudes pushing strollers well I guess
it's Halloween it would have been there
it would have been something there
um anyway it's it's been uh it's been a
joy so far I I would say that if your
husband is on the fence you just got to
keep talking about it you got to talk it
through he maybe he won't get to the
other side
um but you got to talk about it's like
what is what is the point of being in a
long-term monogamous if you're in a
monogamous monogamous relationship like
what is really the point and I think the
point is to build something that's
Everlasting that you can then hand to
the Next Generation and the next
generation will hand it to the next
generation and that is a little more
complex when the biology doesn't fully
match up and there are there are other
issues related to that this is exactly
what I got into with Jordan Peterson
it's not just as easy as saying okay
let's let's just create a family just
like that and see how it goes like
you're changing the Paradigm a little
bit you're changing what the traditional
structure looks like you're a little
outside of that it doesn't mean it can't
be as good good it doesn't mean it can't
be better it doesn't mean that the
traditional structure is always great
right plenty of people are born into all
sorts of dysfunctional families but you
really gotta you really really gotta
think about it shmoo says what kind of
shenanigans do you think of the Lefty
dams and establishment Dems and rhinos
will be up to for this midterm election
next week same old same old or something
new and special
well I don't know if uh you saw it last
night I think we're going to show some
clips of it tomorrow Joe Biden gave a
really crazy speech last night of
warning people of the threats to
democracy and that the elections some
elections might take a few days to
figure out who the winners are and this
has been a trend that we've been seeing
more and more and more where people
don't concede on Election night things
get dragged out further it's like this
is why you need secure elections this is
why you need voter ID because we need to
know that night we need to know that
night it's almost it basically is as
simple as that you cannot prolong these
things and give more Credence to the
idea that their Shenanigans have people
dropping things off in the middle of the
night and then cameras go out it's all
the weird stuff that everybody
regardless of your political alignment
we're all kind of seeing and feeling and
this idea that that both sides suddenly
are just never going to agree uh on who
won or lost is a huge problem look this
year by every estimation the Republicans
are going to crush it there is no
momentum behind the Democrats right even
like who's really a Biden supporter
right now who really is out there at a
rally excited for Biden who's out there
excited for Charlie Crist who's out
there excited for Kathy hochel who's out
there excited for more government
control and more money now I get it a
certain set of people let's say 30
percent of the electorate is always
going to vote blue Democrat no matter
what maybe it's more than that maybe
it's 40 percent and then you have this
other marginal 10 that can push them
over or or crush them so there's a
certain amount of NPCs and people that
are just you know completely just duped
by the system
but this year it's like there is
momentum what is happening in New York
the the thing that that started here in
Florida has now been exported and I'm
telling you guys if we can just get
through Tuesday and Tuesday is good look
will they to directly answer your
question will they likely start violence
in the streets again if they feel like
they're losing power and they need to
just like distract the machine or the
machine needs to distract the people
yeah they'll start some violence in the
streets again will they claim I mean
suddenly it will go that you weren't
allowed to question elections for four
years and then suddenly they'll all be
saying it right what's what is Stacey
Abrams who already denied an election
last time what's she doing right now we
played you the clip a couple days ago
CNN is reporting record early voting
turnout at the same time as she's saying
there is going to be fraud there's no
evidence of it again just you have to
just what do you see in front of your
eyes where is the video of all of the
black people being turned around where
is any evidence that anyone that wants
to vote cannot vote they keep saying it
Hillary says she literally Lee she said
she literally has evidence that the mega
Republicans are going to steal the
election well okay lady how about you
literally show it to me how about that
Caesar says what's your latest dad joke
you've dropped on the people oh my god
well you guys are bludgeoned with these
things all day I mean my main dad joke
is you know there's a lot of poop and
pee around here and now we have kids
it's a lot
um
what else though that's really my main
one that's I mean I'm dropping that one
two four seven times a day it can be
quite yeah Daphne's like ready to vomit
right now it's uh it's pretty bad uh
Delaney says Dave how conflicted are you
with the possible 2024 presidential
candidates well look if you're if you're
really asking you know about the Trump
DeSantis situation first off let me say
one more time I've said it many times I
have no idea whether Ron DeSantis wants
to run for president I know the guy
freaking loves Florida I know that he is
doing a bang-up job here I cannot
imagine anyone being a better chief
executive of the state if you think
about how quickly the Reconstruction of
Southwest Florida has gone after
Hurricane Ian I mean just everything
here has been run so well the apparatus
of the state is tight it's it's
exporting into the cities guys like
Francis Suarez mayor of Miami who I had
on a couple weeks ago it's like there is
such a culture of Freedom here and I'm
meeting all sorts of people
all sorts of people who get it uh not
only is it is it the new people who are
here but there were sort of like you
know half kind of Democrats half
Republicans or a lot of the people who
came from New York even years ago before
covid who come down here and then they
kind of vote the right the wrong way
they're waking up to it so it's like
there there's some goodness here but I
don't know well there's a ton of
goodness here but I don't know what
DeSantis wants to do would he make an
excellent president obviously and if
there is a uh massive red wave as I just
said it will it will be because it
started here in Florida right you guys
saw that ad we showed you at the show at
the end of the show yesterday it's like
well that's the thing that we want to
export to America we want to we want to
export Floridian americanism to America
if that makes sense and I think we're
doing it but so if there is that red
wave and it feels like boy the culture
is Shifting and the pl the politics of
all this are shifting and we've sort of
defeated the woke at The Ballot Box in
many ways and culturally like people
have had it with the eight-month
abortions they've had it with chopping
kids genitals off they've just had it
right
then it's like if DeSantis could then
come in and just be like hey I'm the
president for everybody I'm going to do
this in more of a Reagan style way
there's going to be an aspirational
meaning to my presidency and I'm going
to be confident in all the things look
will the media still try to destroy him
of course of course of course as I keep
saying he'll he'll be they'll say he's
Trump but he's competent so he's double
Hitler right but there's a real argument
that that at that point once the culture
has shifted once the politics game has
shifted that he's the most functional
guy to go forward I think you can make a
good argument for Trump too the good
argument for Trump is he came in once he
shook this thing up more than anybody
and he could do it again and this time
hopefully he would have learned from his
mistakes I think the the
counter to that in terms of just like
the pure numbers of Elections is how
many new people could Trump bring in
there would be a certain amount of
disaffected Democrats a certain amount
of people that are just like Biden's
awful the Democrats are awful I guess
I'll vote for Trump but there's also by
Trump
running you basically get a certain
amount of people who would not vote to
vote just because they hate him so it's
a little more complex I just think
that's the reality that being said I
like them both I think if I think they
should do it on the DL whatever that
Arrangement needs to be but if they have
to do it on stage and battle it out it's
like that's okay that's what politics is
all about uh galerish says which would
be easier opening a one-time
opening a Time port or a la Avengers end
game to travel back in time to keep the
second Star Wars series of movies from
being made or getting the federal
government to spend less than it takes
in Just for kicks to see what it feels
like
well first off I think by the second set
of movies I actually think you might be
in the third set of movies if you know
my feelings on this because the second
set of movies the prequels as I've been
saying for years they're actually pretty
good and they're looking better over
time if you're talking about these last
three movies which were horrible and
ruined Star Wars and all of that stuff
then I went yeah which would was the
question which would be more difficult
which would be more difficult to do
right or which would I rather do
wait I gotta I want to get this right
which would be easier I mean getting the
federal government to spend less money
it's impossible I think it would be more
worthy of getting out there finding some
plutonium from libyans building a flux
capacitor and getting into a time
machine and doing that because the
federal government is never going to get
it's never going to tighten its belt
it's just not how it works next up what
do we have here Elizabeth says besides
the freedom what's your favorite part of
living in Florida let me try to come up
with a different one because okay
there's the spirit of freedom and then I
always say it's like the people their
people are just great everyone is just
great here people are happy and
functional and decent and warm and nice
and you know down here in Miami area
it's like there's so many cultures here
and and it's diversity not just because
it matters that this guy happens to be
Cuban and this guy's white and this
guy's whatever but it's like just like
all this different food and like it's
all good what else is great I mean this
is this is obvious the weather like
right now first off the summer wasn't
bad it really wasn't in bed my hair was
a little lower but now it's the fall so
it's getting higher again because of the
humidity but the weather is great
um
you know what the lizards I like the
lizards I've become a reptile guy you
know there was always one kid in high
school that had reptiles and you were
like you got to stay away from that kid
nobody want you had you know because
they were always up to something else
probably not so great I like reptiles
okay I like iguanas I like frogs I like
lizards I don't care what you think
there there you go Rebecca says can the
Republicans stand up and ask the Dems to
pledge that they will accept the results
of this election we will win and they
will try to overturn it yeah you know
it's interesting and you're getting to
something from the the previous question
look look what happened right here in
Florida during the the Republican Senate
debate there's a Woman by the name of
Val demings I think she was a police
chief in Orlando before this if I'm not
mistaken she's running as the Democrat
and she's running against Marco Rubio
now there's every reason to believe that
Rubio will win he's generally liked here
the state's obviously going very red
he's associated with DeSantis so it's
it's all looking good for for Marco
Rubio but again it's an election you
just never know what's going to happen
at the debate which was about a week and
a half ago the the moderator asked the
two of them will you accept the results
and Rubio said yes we have secure
elections here he said yeah I'm going to
win but yeah we have secure elections
here of course I'm going to respect it
demings would not quite say that Hillary
Clinton running around saying she has
evidence that they're planning to steal
an election except she won't show you
the evidence Stacy Abrams the four years
that all of these people pretended that
Russia installed president Trump and
there were 42 CI uh FBI CIA agents who
had all signed on to say that something
weird happened and a fake impeachment
over the whole freaking thing
it's it's going to be tough but again
this is why at the very least you would
want voter ID you would want a actual uh
signature match right we'd want some
cameras in some of these places you'd
want less uh mail-in ballots but they
want more balance mail-in ballots it's
like
you just got to see it man you just got
to see it Sweetwater says did you have a
hard time finding a home you both liked
when you moved to Florida so you know we
moved it's just under a year ago we got
to Florida on December 17 2021 a day I
will never forget as I've said to you
guys that moment when we were in the
plane and the plane landed and I was
lucky enough we had we had friends who
hooked us up and so we were able to fly
private because I really didn't want to
put Clyde under the plane you know
because every now and again you hear
these horror stories of dogs that are
under the plane and the pressurized
cabins and all sorts of bad stuff so we
had friends that that really helped us
out uh so I was sitting in the cockpit
of the plane when it landed and we were
getting to the landing strip and I'm
telling you that the wheels hit the
ground I felt something lift off my
chest I wanted to get out so badly we
were so excited to be here so we moved
uh got here December 17th we we found
this house it was Halloween weekend so
it was literally a year ago right now
and we saw about 20 places is you know
the key thing is we wanted a house that
would be functional to have my team
working here so we needed a certain
amount of space and we needed uh
something this this room that we're
doing this in that's our studio now
actually was a movie theater uh the guy
who owned the house previously it was a
it was a bedroom that he converted to a
movie theater so it was fully
soundproofed it worked for the lighting
and all that stuff that's why this all
looks pretty good and we didn't have to
do a tremendous amount of work to to uh
to expand on that
um and uh yeah so we saw about 20 places
this was the only house that we both we
walked into this house
and we were like this is the house this
is the house also they had in the house
we're not using it right now because of
the kids but they have this uh this
scent stuff What's That Brand you know
what the brand is that has the scents
that run through the house you know like
when you go to a hotel or you go to a
casino and you walk in and the air just
has a certain scent to it there's oh I
think it's called Aroma 360. is the
company that does it but we walk in this
house and they just had this lovely
scent going throughout the house so you
can get different essential oils and put
it in there but we walked in it's a
beautiful house also it was nice because
uh the house is kind of a v so the the
portion of the V that we're in right now
is sort of our work portion although my
bedroom is right downstairs the master
bedroom but it's a we got all the work
stuff going on over here all the life
stuff going on over here so it worked
out nicely and we have kind of similar
taste and everything so it wasn't uh it
wasn't that big a lift and there was a
basketball court so I was pretty much
willing to buy a sight unseen uh Roman
says did you find it amazing at how many
celebrities don't appear to have eight
dollars a month to pay for Twitter
verification so if you have not seen
this as I always say if you are not on
Twitter don't get on Twitter but the big
brouhaha over the last couple days is
that Elon Musk originally said that he
was going to charge people twenty
dollars a month for the blue
verification that's just a little blue
check next to your name uh and he said
that he wanted to charge people for it
because it would be a way of generating
Revenue that then they could perhaps
give to creators also he's trying to get
the company to be profitable you know
that's what you do when you buy a
company anyway he got a little pushback
on that then it they somehow came up
with eight dollars a month that so for
eight dollars a month you could get a
little blue check and that you might get
some bonus uh features along with that
like your notifications might be
organized a little bit differently you
might show up in search a little bit
more listen I think there's all sorts of
reasons that a sort of pay to play thing
is not necessarily the best idea
especially when it comes to search and
all that
that being said I also think there's
huge amounts of benefits to having a
certain level of pay for play which is
exactly why we did locals the way we did
the fact that I only take questions
right now from people who put in a
couple dollars a month it it makes
things more mature it makes everyone's
Behavior better when you have a little
skin in it you act a little bit
differently we don't allow for a million
burner accounts so anyway I think I
think having some level of subscription
some level of ads like you can figure
out how to mix these things all together
and that's what a mature internet maybe
on the other side of all this craziness
will look like but yes there was a huge
amount of celebrities and and
journalists Etc that were basically like
I'm never gonna pay Elon Musk eight
dollars it's like man you pay eight
bucks at Starbucks for a venti
cappuccini macchiati uh thing with the
ice there and the half the things nice
anyway
so yes these people just it's like look
I would say one thing about the
verification thing verification
originally was set up not as a money
maker but just to prove that you were
who you were right because there are
there are people who impersonate me
steal my picture pretend that they're me
they spell my name one letter were off
and then they confuse people so the
verification was just really so that oh
if you saw Dave Rubin at Reuben report
you knew it was the Dave Rubin so the
idea that you would start selling this
so anyone could be verified
it changes a little bit of what
verification is and once everyone is
sort of verified then is anyone verified
that being said he said that the other
piece of this was that he wanted to get
rid of bots and spam accounts and it's
like Bots are not going to pay eight
dollars a month to be Bots or whoever is
sending those Bots right that's not
going to work for them so yeah these are
all the things he has to work out but
watching people go crazy eight dollars a
month I'm not good all right come on
uh Lynn says where are you having
Thanksgiving dinner and what's on the
menu so Thanksgiving is the one major
holiday that we host with David's family
and his mom and and Grandma and sister
and brother and sister-in-law and all
sorts of people come do we have some
pictures of some of the food we we I'm
very fortunate to uh that is last year's
turkey which Oh Mamma Mia just perfect
we got some fresh cranberry sauce right
there on its way to Cranberry sauce
looks like some sweet potatoes over
there what else do we got anything else
anything else and some butternut squash
soup with a little chipotle pepper in
there uh just absolutely perfect uh so
yeah we do host that uh Thanksgiving
here this will be our first Thanksgiving
in Florida obviously uh no yeah no it
will be our first Thanksgiving in
Florida and uh we are very thankful for
Florida so uh it should be a good one
and uh yeah I just love Thanksgiving
like just having one day where it's a
holiday that's it's a purely secular
America in Holiday it's a celebration of
America nothing else just hey it's
pretty freaking good here be thankful
for it one of the things that I always
think is interesting about Thanksgiving
is when you see the reaction online of
certain people because the the lefties
unfortunately in the walksters they're
always attacking Thanksgiving now right
they're and that they're not thankful
for anything and I think a little a
little thankfulness a little humility a
little understanding of why you should
be so freaking thankful to live in this
country uh it's pretty good it's pretty
good talway says now that you're a dad
who uh do you think the do you do you
think you view the world the culture
wars and the political world any
differently than you did before you're a
dad
well
not differently but I think it's it's
kind of renewed or doubled down like I
really got to make sure that the world
is in good shape uh when I'm gone right
because now I have kids that I it is my
responsibility and my duty to make sure
that they live in the best world
possible
um you know another part of just sort of
this isn't exactly what your question
was but I I think I said something like
this a couple weeks ago another part of
this whole experience and journey that
we're just at the beginning of that's
been really nice is so much of my life
is about me right like I do this show
people I go places people say hi to me I
am invited places so that I can speak
it's a lot of it's a lot of me and
that's great in one way and very
rewarding and validating that I've done
something I guess pretty decent here and
that what I'm saying and what I care
about actually matters that's actually
really wonderful
um but it all it can be a little
maddening too right I think that's why
so many celebrities go nuts it's why
comedians go crazy it's why you know
public people will do drugs and like
lose their [ __ ] like I think there's
some connection there between like the
endless ego part of it so you know just
laying there this morning again this
morning I'm up at 7 15. I'm taking I
take the kids for the first hour and
it's just me Luke was pretty much out
this morning but Justin is up he's you
know he's rolling into month three now
and he's he's not talking but he's
making a lot of sounds now he's trying
to talk like there's something going on
there and he's smiling at me and I tell
him a little bit I was at the same time
I was emailing with Phoenix going back
and forth on how we're going to do the
show and I I just kind of read it to
Jessica what do you think about this
what do you think we're gonna do this
Joe Biden thing you think and it's like
it's been good it's been good uh Kate
says will you be doing any live
streaming on Election night well I guess
we can tell people our election plans uh
so on Election night uh so on Election
Day which is next Tuesday I'll be doing
a show here and then we are hopping in a
car and we are going cross state up
north to uh Northwest Florida which is
where Tampa is and that is where uh the
DeSantis campaign will be having their
obvious uh Victory event Victory party
that night uh so I and Lisa Booth from
Fox News you guys know Lisa Booth we are
co-hosting the DeSantis Victory party so
that's going to be awesome we'll be on
and off stage all night we'll be
announcing results as they come in uh
just just going to be a fun celebration
of freedom in America and all that and I
will also do a show from there so a
little bit of that we have to do on the
fly but we will do a show at some point
throughout the evening uh hopefully I
can get Governor DeSantis to join me and
you know there's obviously campaign
surrogates and some of my my Florida
crew that you guys know will be there so
we're going to do it a bit on the fly so
I don't know exactly what time it is
because I'm also gonna have to jump off
and be on stage and do the show and all
that and then we're also going to try to
simulcast some of that with the guys at
the blaze uh Glenn and the whole crew
over there who I love they wanted me to
go to Dallas for election night which I
thought would be great and we could do
five hours of coverage together it'll be
it would be fun and awesome but
obviously once I got the the invite from
the governor um I was going to do that
so yes party that night uh live stream
and uh just bear with us we'll figure it
out but it is definitely going to be a
celebration of Freedom that night Lloyd
says as we tape the last of our seeming
17
000 boxes for our escape from crazy Cali
to Idaho congratulations my wife says we
have a lot of stuff not stuff but a
lifetime of memories when you move did
you downsize at all has it all fit into
the new studio house and studio
um well first off congratulations on
getting out and I'm sure you're gonna
love it Idaho and it's good to get out
of Cali Cali Cali is the most sort of
banged up state that we've got they have
made their choice with Gavin Newsom like
he's about to be re-elected again
there's just no doubt about it it's a
far gone conclusion New York has a
chance
actually polls
the last two days are showing Lee zeldin
in the lead and as I keep saying about
hochul nobody voted for her she was
installed so she loses a little bit of
that incumbents you know incumbents
usually win because people are sort of
mindless when they go in and they just
click things oh I recognize that name
but nobody's ever clicked Kathy hochel
before nobody's ever ticked that swiped
it you know checked it whatever you want
to say so I think zeldin really has a
chance so congratulations first off on
leaving California it's wonderful you're
going to live in a new place with new
people and you're going to flourish and
Thrive there's just no doubt about it
and and I can tell you that because not
only has that worked for me and
everybody that's in that the studio with
me right now that we've we've all built
Better Lives once we left but then you
start meeting other people that left and
when you when you're suddenly around
some people who leave for a reason you
find common cause in sustaining the
thing that you came to and that is a
beautiful thing that is a really really
beautiful thing I think it's one of the
reasons that Florida is going so red
because people are like yes I am going
to save this freaking thing because you
guys saved me
um so the question was about memories
and all the stuff that we had you know
we gave away a whole bunch of stuff
actually I gave away uh we had a whole
bunch of outdoor furniture that we had
just got in Cali but I couldn't move
everything we had two trucks going and
it was just starting to get nuts so I
gave a whole bunch of our outdoor
furniture to Patricia Heaton you may
remember Patricia Heaton as the wife and
Everybody Loves Raymond her and her
husband Dave became good friends of ours
and they were having we had a final
dinner in Los Angeles I think two nights
before we left with Dennis Prager and
his wife Sue and Larry Elder and his
girlfriend and uh and Dave and Patricia
came by and I was like hey you guys want
some stuff so we just started giving
some stuff away but uh yeah we I gave
some clothes away and stuff like that
unfortunately we've got some it's a
pretty decent sized house here we've got
some storage so we're still not unpacked
one Monday will get unpacked I suppose
right before we move again Jeb says Dave
you keep asking everyone what their
election predictions are but what are
your election predictions uh you know I
wrote out a map that they're going to
debut on Election night for the blaze
um
but look I really think Selden is going
to win in New York that's the that's the
one that I think is the big one okay
um obviously Florida will remain red I
think Oz has got to win Pennsylvania it
is almost Beyond imagination that
fetterman could win okay so I think Oz
will win there I do think Blake Masters
is going to win in Arizona as well as
Cary Lake like I really think the Senate
it could be end up 54 Republicans I know
that's bullish and you know I know we're
all in our own little Bubbles and
all that stuff but I I just think
people have had it with the woke there
are no rallies for Democrats everyone
knows even the most Arden Biden
supporter knows that something is not
right with Joe Biden like
there's no momentum there they're
prepping us for no momentum and the
ideas were bad all they had to do was
not be horrible uh what what are you
showing me here real clear politics is
now predicting that New Hampshire will
even get a Republican senator so there
is real real momentum here and and again
I just think you know it's funny while
the meme out there if you listen to
mainstream media will be if the
Republicans take over we'll have Fascism
and homophobia and bigotry and all of
these things it's like how about we just
end up like Florida is what if Florida
just exported americanism right and what
if people just started Living their
lives more the way they wished you know
like I don't see any bigotry down here
it's odd I certainly don't see fascism I
see a government that kind of gets out
of your way and then you know what
happens when a massive basically
category five storm crushes part of the
state within two three weeks almost all
the infrastructure is rebuilt that we do
everything we can the government when
necessary comes in and does the right
thing that's what we can get back to and
uh I think if we export that if we
export that the the woke thing it could
it could go away pretty quickly as I
said it's not going to fully go away and
there'll always be a set of of
anti-American hysterical lunatics but if
a couple of the states flip and the
Senate goes back and we stop spending
money like crazy people and we honestly
start having some of these debates again
and we get leaders in who are functional
and decent we could really get back to
the dream in the 90s we really could it
was the dream of the 1890s and the 1990s
actually uh guys stick around for the
cold clothes as always if you want to
play along during our q and A's and live
chat during any of the shows you can
join us at
reubenreport.locals.com we've got a
panel for you tomorrow it's our final
panel before the big election uh Michael
malis we haven't had malice on in a
while I'm psyched for that lawyer Ron
Coleman we're going to talk a little bit
about uh you know the the government and
Twitter and big Tech coordinating to
clamp down on your free speech what is
your ability to to get penalties from
them get money from them sue the
government Etc and then Viva fry who
also uh uh is a lawyer former Canadian
now proud Floridian so it'll be malice
Coleman and Frye uh tomorrow and uh and
Viva was just suspended on Twitter this
week post Elon so we're gonna have to
talk about that he had a theory about
Nancy Pelosi that I guess the powers
that bee didn't really like
and we leave you as we brought you in
with the elderly man pretending to be
president see you tomorrow
I just have one thing to say
there you go there
all right
[Music]
there you go
[Music]
I tell you what if I had to tell him any
one of these people I'd be I'd be
elected president by acclimation